Has to be embarrassing for their husbands
when they take them to work parties.
All the educated women having conversations,
while all she knows is stain removal from laundry.
Yep, that's us.
We don't really do anything.
Unless you count cooking, cleaning,
homeschooling our children,
coaching our kids, sports teams.
Using our own bodies to create,
grow, and feed babies.
Creating and maintaining a home,
overseeing the physical, emotional,
psychological well being of children.
Being on call for them 24 hours a day,
seven days a week, and just keeping them alive every single day.
Like, if you set those things aside,
we do nothing. And what's ironic is that if you ask these exact people,
do you value the profession of house cleaner,
cook, teacher,
party planner, chauffeur,
interior decorator, nurse,
psychiatrist, mediator?
They would all say, yes.
Of course. The work that those people do is important to our world,
to our society. But when they see a woman doing all of those things,
and not for a paycheck, but just because she wants to,
she's actually not doing anything at all.
Stay at home moms know that they'll be looked down on.
We know that what we do isn't making money.
But we also know that some of the most valuable,
impactful work in this world isn't paid.
And we also know how to remove stains from laundry. Yes.